Speaker 1: Former Republican Congressman
Devin Nunes, who is affiliated with Donald
Trump's social media platform Truth Social
appeared on Fox News the other day, and
he unleashed a dizzying array of conspiracy
theories. When asked about the documents
seized from Donald Trump's Mar a Lago home
as a result of the FBI's search warrant,
and I actually am not even sure what the total
number is. This is really something. The question
is about the documents and the search warrant from
Maria BARTIROMO. And Devin Nunes tries to blame
Obama. Benghazi. I mean, it's just completely
all over the place. See if you can count the
number of completely unrelated conspiracy theories
that Nunes mentions here. And the sad thing is,
this is what the right is adopting as their
perspective on the search warrant. Obama Benghazi.
Witch Hunt. Robert Mueller. Fast and Furious.
Whatever. Check this out. Try to count them up.
Speaker 4: So. So, Devin Nunes, you came
out with the Nunes memo in 2018 and exposed
all of them. Is it the same documents
that they want to have under lock and
key that they wanted to get from Trump at home?
Speaker 3: Well, look, I don't think we know that
because and I'm not sure they even got a whole lot
of documents anyway. They haven't even accounted
for them. But Maria, I would only disagree with
cash. I don't normally disagree with Cache,
but I think this actually goes back three
Russiagate hoax. I think this goes back to the
IRS scandal where they targeted conservatives.
Speaker 1: Now there's that's three. Okay.
The current FBI search warrant is over. Stuff that
Trump took home in 2021. It has nothing to do with
the Russia hoax or the Russia probe. Number two,
the Russia probe was not a hoax. It actually found
was that there were 34 indictments of individuals
and three more of companies or something like
that. And the IRS scandal where they targeted
conservatives wasn't really a thing. It actually
turned out that they were more or less equally
looking at organizations based on liberal and
conservative leaning keywords. So we're already
three. He's only been speaking for 10 seconds and
we're already three conspiracy theories in heck.
Speaker 3: It goes back to Fast and Furious during
the Obama administration, where they ran guns
and tried to set people up, remember? And then
innocent Americans ended up getting killed.
Speaker 1: Now, Fast and Furious was a program
where federal agents allowed some guns
to be sold and brought into Mexico
so they could trace the weapons. And you
can argue it was a bad idea, but it wasn't
started under Obama. And it also has nothing
whatsoever to do with what's happening with
Donald Trump right now.
Speaker 3: It goes back
to Benghazi. They got away with that.
Speaker 1: Now. They didn't get away
with anything with Benghazi. This is conspiracy.
Is this conspiracy theory? Five or six so far,
no one got away with Benghazi. It
wasn't something to get away with.
It was a tragedy because people died. Hillary
Clinton was investigated in a dozen hearings.
She testified under oath for more than 8 hours,
something Donald Trump has never done. And she
was found not responsible. But again, what does
it have to do with this search warrant? Nothing.
Speaker 3: You have to remember, it was late
2015 or 16 that we get to the plan where the
Clinton campaign working with dirty cops
at DOJ and FBI and the media, I must say,
where they set up to spy on the Trump
campaign and ultimately Republicans and
frame an innocent man that then led.
Speaker 1: That never happened.
I mean, in 2015, 2016, Hillary Clinton did not
work with dirty cops and the media to set up to
spy on the Trump campaign. It didn't happen. This
is the Trump thing. They spied on my campaign. I'm
sure some of you have heard Trump say that they
spied on my campaign. No. What happened was in 20,
it's actually it's an it's a huge indictment of
the Trump campaign. What actually happened? What
actually happened is that the Trump campaign in
2016 was regularly in contact with so many people
under surveillance by the FBI that in surveilling
their targets, the FBI stumbled across
conversations with people in the Trump campaign.
So, like I'm going to give you an example. Right?
Imagine that Joe Schmo is under FBI surveillance.
Don Jr then get out gets on the phone with Joe
Schmo. So there's a recording of Joe Schmo. His
conversation with Don Jr. Don Jr is incidental to
the entire thing. It's Joe Schmo who's under
surveillance. And because the Trump campaign
in 2015, 2016 was in touch with so many people
who were of interest. To law enforcement. They
ended up, coincidentally, on some signals
intelligence. It's an insane story, but as
Devin Nunes tells it, it's completely untrue.
Speaker 3: To what? So that was the Russia hoax
that then led to the Mueller witch hunt.
Speaker 1: So, okay. And again,
the Mueller witch hunt led to 34 indictments of
people. Three indictments of companies recovered
more money than it cost and was unable to say
that Donald Trump did not commit obstruction.
That's the truth. Of the so-called Mueller hoax
witch hunt, whatever it is he calls it. Are we up
to seven conspiracy theories here or maybe eight?
Speaker 3: This stuff is intertwined. And
then you just fast forward, you know, cast
mention, you know, the Whitmer case and Jan
six and whether or not federal agents
were involved in that. So you just stare.
Speaker 1: And that's another conspiracy theory.
Were federal agents involved in January 6th?
There is no evidence that federal agents were
involved in January 6th. This is the inside job, a
conspiracy theory. Some people will just generally
cited it and say it was a it was an inside job. It
was actually some people will say it was Antifa
or Black Lives Matter. Others will say it was the
FBI that actually did the Trump riots. Now, there
is a guy named Ray Epps, which many on the right
fixated on a guy who was at the at the Capitol
the day before the riots. And I think the day of
and people have asserted without evidence that Ray
Epps is an FBI agent. There's no evidence of that,
and there is no evidence that federal agents
were involved in January six. I think that
that's eight conspiracy theories, at least.
Speaker 3: And then ultimately, this leads to
what this leads to something never done
in American history before. You had a
president's home ransacked by the same
goons that were involved in all of this.
And I would say that that, you know, a
lot of people have criticized, you know.
Speaker 1: And that is not a conspiracy theory,
but it's just a very dumb topic talking point
that this has never been done to a president in
American history. That's not really anything.
Endless things happen in the world. And at
some point, they happen for the first time.
No president has done the things that Donald
Trump has done before. And so it shouldn't
come as such a big shock that the outcomes have
also been different. This is absolutely nuts.
Eight conspiracy theories in about 90 seconds
of Devin Nunes speaking and all sorts of other
deranged and nonsensical statements like this has
never happened before and therefore it's bad. And
unfortunately, they just not along on Fox News.
Mm hmm. Maria BARTIROMO and Kash Patel. Mm hmm.
This stuff spreads like wildfire. We
already saw it in interviews done with
protesters outside Mar a Lago, repeating a lot of
these same things. It's never been done before.
What about Benghazi? What about Obama gate? Which
we still haven't even figured out what it is.
It works and it's a circle. They say it because
the followers believe it and because the followers
believe that they're encouraged to continue saying
these things. And then it's just a circle of trash
rather than a circle of truth. The
circle of truth is nowhere to be found.